some things you can't put into words
just because I've been there for so long
and so many great memories great people
obviously the best fans in the world
because they they come with it and
tonight they came with excuse me the
organization Sam mr. Bennett you know
they do an amazing job of just making
you feel home and I feel like I was on
yeah of course I never been in there so
I mean definitely the whole thing is a
little weird coming into the bidding
going there and even going through that
tunnel but once I got back on the court
I felt like I was back you know doing
the same thing I always been doing the
last few years said again yeah I'm it
started with my clothing line
honestly that was a call out and I get
probably to do something for the the
city for the people and me and my team
we came up with zero regrets in
something and I um Creole if you try to
figure out what I can do for the city
and I don't forget one thing being an
Oklahoma City
I don't know regret sign it back I don't
regret staying here I don't regret
anything that I did here I feel like I
left everything out on the floor every
single night dude I cook for the city
Russell a lot of great players have come
here and moved on they haven't done that
kind of video tribute for anybody what
did it mean to you to be the first one I
mean it special you know it's a very
very special thing that meant a lot to
me honestly and coming back here just
making me feel
like I was very very appreciated
appreciate it and I appreciate it a lot
Russ after the game you went over and do
Clay Bennett a hug I think our burries
Widow as well or what made you decide
that's something you wanted to do mr.
Benn has done a lot for me my family he
has done things go unnoticed he's always
very very supportive of anything I've
ever done for the city while I was here
in Oklahoma the fans headed people they
never did me no wrong
I have nothing no bad blood and nothing
here in the city from no fans no no mine
organization because they gave me all
they have and I gave my life